You often mentioned disciplining
children,
so they behave.
What is your advice for making them
behave without resorting to corporal
punishment?
Well,
first of all,
it depends on what you mean by corporal
punishment.
Um,
time out could be regarded as corporal
punishment.
It also depends very much on the age of
the child,
um,
at say a two year old,
well in my new book,
by the way,
I have a chapter in there called don't
let your children do anything that makes
you dislike them.
And the reason that I wrote a chapter
about that is because people who let
their children do things that make them
dislike them,
end up disliking them.
And because there's a huge power
differential,
generally speaking between adults and
children,
if you end up disliking your children
because they're not behaving well,
they're behaving disgracefully say,
or they're,
or they're challenging your position in
the authority hierarchy to regularly,
uh,
something you won't put up with.
By the way,
even if you think you will,
it's necessary to get your disciplinary
routine straight.
So the first thing I would say is figure
out what the rules are.
There shouldn't be too many for two year
olds.
Basically.
They have to know what no means.
And they also have to learn as they
approach three,
not to kick,
hit bite or steel.
Essentially.
Now it's easy to train a two year old.
What no means you can actually start
with a child that's only 13 months old
child that can cry,
let's say that or that can crawl.
Let's say that you have a child at
starting to crawl and wants to explore
the house.
So the first thing you do,
if you have any senses,
try to get rid of most things that the
child could cause a tremendous amount of
trouble with,
uh,
to,
to the things or to the child so that
it's reasonably safe.
Um,
and then the child is gonna wanna want
crawl around and get into everything.
And so,
but maybe there are things you don't
want him or her to get into.
Like maybe there's a.
Oh,
what would we say?
Maybe there's a tablecloth.
And on top of the table cloth,
there's a plant,
or maybe there's some plants on the
floor and when the child is crawling and
goes off to do something that he or she
shouldn't,
you can just grab his leg and you know
gently but firmly and say no,
and the child will keep trying to move
forward because they're stubborn little
blinders and you can continue to say no.
And if you persist with saying no,
then the child will eventually give up
and sort of go limp.
Now.
Now and often the child will cry when
you do that,
and of course that might make you feel
guilty.
But what that means is that you've
effectively brought to behavior to a
halt.
And if you do that 10 times,
you've got to watch your child and don't
stop them from exploring things that
they need to explore.
And you want to use this sort of thing
with judiciously.
You can grab them by the leg and say,
no,
no.
And wait until they give up.
Usually they'll cry and then you can let
them go.
And then soon after,
you do that,
about 10 times soon.
Then if you just say no with the same
tone of voice,
the child will generally what happens,
the child will immediately cry and then
stop.
And then after about 10 repeats of no
without having the late grabbed,
then no,
we'll just produce stopping of the
behavior.
And that's unbelievably useful because
as soon as you're.
You train your child to understand what
no means,
then they really have free reign of the
house in some sense with relatively
minimal supervision from you.
First of all,
they can learn what things they're not
supposed to get into.
And it's amazing how fast children can
learn that and how fast they can
generalize to the class of things that
they shouldn't get into.
Like you don't have to teach them every
single thing.
They can generalize very rapidly.
That's not much different than thinking,
but also once they are capable of
understanding what no means,
you have an extremely potent means of
helping them regulate their behavior
with a minimum of intervention.
So that's unbelievably useful.
So now let's say you have a two year old
who's pretty contentious and two year
olds are pretty contentious.
Some of them in particular because both
five percent of two year olds,
most of them are male,
are quite aggressive by temperament and
those are the ones that if you put with
other two year olds will frequently kick
hit,
bite or steel.
Not all kids are like that,
but some are and most of them get
socialized out of that by the time
they're about four.
Now let's say you have an at two,
they also start to experiment with
saying,
no,
I'm back.
And also with misbehaving,
although they can do that even younger
than that.
So if you have a two year old who's
particularly rambunctious and who
decides he isn't going to listen to you,
we use he in this example because it's
boys that are more likely to misbehave
and not,
uh,
not listen.
You can,
you can pick them up and you know by the
arms,
now you got to get your attitude right
because you don't want to be stupid.
You don't want to let your kid make you
mad.
Especially when they're really little
because you're really big and you can
hurt them and so you gotta you gotTa
have a clue.
That's why you want to get the rules of
discipline in order,
the minimum rules of discipline and why
you want to have a strategy,
but let's say you're a two or two year
old is insisting upon doing something
that you don't want him to do.
Like a inserting a fork into an
electrical outlet and you just can't
have that and so you can say no.
Hopefully you've already done the no
training that I recommended and if that
doesn't work,
what I recommend doing is picking the
child up by the arms and then putting
them on the steps.
Say,
look,
you sit there until you're ready to
listen.
Now I'm usually the child will sit there
and then the rule has to be something
like you can get up as soon as you're
ready to be a civilized human being
again and you can refer to yourself,
your own attitude during a process like
that.
Because if the child does comply and
sits on the steps and then comes and
says,
I'm ready to be good,
and you like them again,
you got to be honest about this.
Then you can tell that he's honest in
his decision to rejoin the civilized
world.
Now sometimes if you put a two year old
that's particularly rambunctious on the
staircase,
that as soon as you let go of their
arms,
they'll run off and that can be a game
or it can just be an act of defiance and
in that case then you go get them and he
put them back on the steps and you do
that several times if necessarily if
that.
That becomes a game.
Then you sit on the step and you hold
him by the arms.
Remember,
no anger because he's just too,
for God sake.
You know you don't have to be angry,
is put them on the steps and hold them.
Say,
look,
I'm not letting you go until you sit
there and behave,
and so if you hold him for a while,
he'll squirm and look away and so forth,
but you can get his attention.
If you're a little bit stubborn,
you hold them there and say you're going
to sit there until I decide that you can
leave and so you hold them and he'll
squirm and.
But you can outwait them if you're a
patient,
but you got to make the time and then
eventually he'll stop squirming and you
can let them go and then you can sit
there and watch him and when you think
he's,
you know,
decided that he's going to be a
civilized creature.
Then you can say that's good and you can
give them a pat on the head and you can
say,
let's go back and do what we're doing,
and the rule has to be.
You see that the punishment not only has
to bring the behavior to a halt in the
most merciful manner possible,
but it's still effective,
but it also has to satisfy your need for
order and justice so that you don't
carry resentment and irritation about
the child's misbehavior forward with you
because you don't want a kid yourself
about what sort of Nice person you are.
You're not nearly as nice a person as
you think and no one likes to be brought
down the authority hierarchy by a
recalcitrant two-year-old.
So in almost all circumstances,
those processes will suffice.
There's other disciplinary strategies
that you can use to that are more
positive.
I mean,
one of the things that you can do,
for example,
if you're.
Let's say you want to get your child to
go to bed,
which is a really good idea.
You should set a stable bedtime for your
child and I would say if they're under
four,
it should be around eight or seven or
something like that because you want to
have a life and you want to have a life
with your wife so that you don't end up
hating your child.
And so one of the things you can do if
you want to train your child to go to
bed at eight,
so maybe he's not going to bed until 10
right now and you want to fix that.
So you say,
okay,
go to the grocery store or a little
convenience store and buy 10 little
gifts and it can be cheap.
Kids don't care.
They're not very bright,
you know,
you can fool them,
so by 10 things that you think your kid
would like and wrap them up and then put
them up on a shelf where he can see them
at,
can't get at them.
Then you say,
look,
kid,
I'm going to put you to bed at 9:30
tonight,
and uh,
if you don't get out of bed then I'm
going to give you one of these.
I'm going to give you one of these gifts
in the morning.
So,
or if the.
Or you can do it another way too.
If the child is always giving you a
rough time about getting ready for bed
and going to bed,
you can say,
look,
if you're,
if you put on your pajamas without
fussing and you climb into bed,
then they'll give you one of these
little gifts.
And so then if that works,
then the child can have a little gift
and he's in bed at 9:30
and then you can make it nine and then
you can make it 8:30.
And then you can make it eight.
And those are called.
That's called success of approximation,
right?
You hit the target,
you specify the target that you want the
child to achieve,
and then use small rewards not too often
in order to attain that goal.
And those are unbelievably effective
strategies and they can actually be
pretty fun.
But I would say the advice to not let
your child do anything that makes you
dislike them is really,
really useful.
Um,
you want to talk this over with your
partner too so that you have your
disciplinary strategies and your rules
talked out so that you don't work at
cross purposes to one another.
So.
Okay,
so that's probably good enough for that.